IT IS DISGUSTING AND AMERICANS
ARE WAKING UP TO THIS, TOM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AS ALWAYS AND LIBERAL CRITICS
SAYING ALL THE PRESIDENT CARES
ABOUT IS THE BORDER WALL.
HE MADE IT CLEAR, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT POLITICS.
>> THIS IS REALLY ON BORDER
SAFETY, BORDER SECURITY AND A
BILL ON I WOULD SAY MAY BE MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE, TALKING
ABOUT DRUG TRAFFICKING.
>> Laura: WELL, JOINING ME
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT
KELLYANNE CONWAY, KELLY AND,
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE'S
MESSAGE TONIGHT >> kellyanne:
TO THOSE REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHO
TO THOSE REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHR
TO THOSE REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHJ
TO THOSE REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHC
TO THOSE REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHT
THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION AND
INCLUDING BREAKS MY HEART
MICHAEL LEE OF UTAH.
>> Laura: MURKOWSKI IT DOESN'T
SURPRISE ME AT ALL BUT MIKE LEE
AND RAND PAUL, YOU ARE ON MY YOU
KNOW WHAT LIST TONIGHT, I'M
SORRY.
IT IS APPALLING.
>> kellyanne: AND A BRIEFING
FOR THE PRESIDENT TODAY, AND
BOTH TIMES HE SAID, TAKE THE
BOAT YOU WANT TO TAKE.
I THINK IT IS A BAD VOTE.
THIS IS AN EASY DECISION AND
QUITE BINARY.
FOR BORDER SECURITY AND FOR
SOVEREIGNTY, KEEPING THE DRUGS
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY, LAURA,
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS OUTCOME OF THE
HUMAN FLOW OF PEOPLE IN
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AND
FAMILIES FOR YOU'RE NOT.
AND HE DOESN'T BELIEVE YOU CAN'T
DIVORCE THE TWO BECAUSE YOU WANT
TO HIDE BEHIND THE PROCESS
ARGUMENT.
HE HAS FOCUSED ON THE SUBSTANCE
HAS HE HAS BEEN FOR FOUR
STRAIGHT YEARS.
THE SUBSTANCE IS SIMPLE: MAKE
YOU LOOK AT THE DRUGS FLOWING IN
AND NOT JUST THE PORTS OF ENTRY
BUT TO TAKE HIM ABOUT LEGAL
SYNTHETIC OPIATES COMING BETWEEN
THE PORTS OF ENTRY.
A VERY IMPORTANT ARTICLE OF THE
FENTANYL FAILURE OF ALL PLACES
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST," THE
FENTANYL FAILURE PLEASE READ IT.
THE FENTANYL FAILURE REFERS TO
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DID
NOTHING, ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
MITIGATE AND CURB THE RISING
SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS THAT NOW HAS
CLAIMED ABOUT 67,000 AMERICANS,
MORE THAN VIETNAM, IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN PUT TOGETHER.
>> Laura: NOT A CRISIS --
BUT KELLY GANN, WHAT HAPPENED ON
CAPITOL HILL?
AND THEY WILL MAKE A
CONSTITUTIONAL ARGUMENT AND I
THINK THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S
OFFICE WAS CLEARLY RIGHT THAT
THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTE DELEGATION
OF CONGRESSIONAL AUTHORITY TO
THE PRESIDENT, 1970s TO
DECLARE AN EMERGENCY.
NOW THEY CLAIM THEY DIDN'T DO
THAT.
WELL, THEY DID IT AND IF THEY
WANT TO THEY SHOULD CHANGE THE
LAW.
BUT ON THIS QUESTION WHAT WILL
HAPPEN NEXT.
THE PRESIDENT WILL VETO THIS IF
IT GETS REJECTED, WHICH IT LOOKS
LIKE IT WILL.
HE WILL VETO IT BUT THEN WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE BORDER WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE WALL?
WHAT HAPPENS?
>> kellyanne: WELL, THE
PRESIDENT WILL LOOK AT THE
OPTIONS.
AND OBVIOUSLY --
>> Laura: LOOKING AT OPTIONS,
KELLY AND WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT THE WALL FOR TWO YEARS, WHAT
OPTIONS?
>> kellyanne: THAT IS NOT HIS
FAULT NOW THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS FAILS HIM.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR HE
WANTED MONEY FOR THE WEALTH
HUNTING AND REMEMBER LAURA HE
SIGNED ON THE BUS PACKAGE HE
SAID I DON'T LIKE IT 716 BILLION
TROOPS, 750 BILLION, ALL THIS
MONEY FOR THE TROOPS AND WE HAVE
OTHER STUFF IN HERE FUNDING,
LIKE THE OPIOID CRISIS AND OTHER
MEASURES, BUT HE SAID DON'T, YOU
ASKED FOR THE WALL FUNDING.
SURE, WE WILL GET THE FUNDING
THIS CONGRESS BUT THEY DID NOT
DO IT NOW DEMOCRATS, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THIS PRESIDENT SAYS EVERY
DAY HE'S MOVING ON WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION.
IN THIS NEW BUDGET HAS
$32.5 BILLION FOR BORDER
SECURITY MEASURES.
THAT INCLUDES BORDER PATROL
AGENTS, THAT INCLUDES
TECHNOLOGY, BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES
MONEY FOR THE WALL.
THE MILITARY CONSTRUCTION FUNDS,
THE DRUG DIVERSION FUNDS --
>> Laura: YOU STILL DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE GETTING THAT MONEY
AND I GET YOU KNOW WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS BUT TONIGHT DO
WE NOT KNOW WHERE WE ARE GETTING
THE MONEY?
YOU HAVE HAD A LOT OF TIME TO
FIGURE THIS OUT.
>> kellyanne: IT'S IN THE
BUDGET AND WE HAVE FIGURED IT
OUT MANY TIMES.
IF THEY WANT TO LOOK AT THE
REPUBLICANS WHO KNOWS THE
PRESIDENT AND FULL LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AFTER HE GAVE THEM
MONTHS TO DO THEIR JOB, LAURA,
THE COURT IN THE CONGRESS HAVE
TO DO THEIR JOBS ON IMMIGRATION
FOR DECADES.
THIS PRESIDENT IS THE
DECLARATION --
>> Laura: I'M NOT TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT -- I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE ARE YOU GETTING
THE MONEY.
WE ARE SPENDING MONEY IN OTHER
COUNTRIES BORDERS, KELLY AND CAN
I GET IT.
SYRIA, IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN BUT
BRING THE MONEY FORM AND ENFORCE
OUR BORDERS, WHAT THE HECK ARE
WE DOING?
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS THE DEMOCRATS LOVE TO SAY
THAT THE PRESIDENT ARE THE
ALLIES COMMIT DEHUMANIZED, LET'S
WATCH.
TRUMP THE HUMAN EYES HIS NAME
CALLS COMMIT DEGENERATES PEOPLE
AND YOU HAVE A MAN WHO HAS THE
HUMAN EYES CHILDREN, TAKING THE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS.
>> THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF THE
TRUMP BRAND.
THIS DEHUMANIZATION OF
EMIGRANTS.
>> Laura: KELLY AND WHAT ARE
THE DEMOCRATS REACTION THEN TO
THIS?
BECAUSE THAT IS SILLY TO EVEN
THINK, ONE IS HUMAN AND THE
OTHER IS NOT.
>> JUST ON THE FACTS, THEY
OUTLASTED EVERYBODY.
AND A SIGN OF LOYALTY WERE
PREEMINENT WITH TRUMP.
NO, I THINK MEDIOCRITY IS AND
IT'S ABOUT TRUMP, YOU REALLY GOT
A PROBLEM.
AND COCKROACHES SURVIVE NUCLEAR
WAR.
>> Laura: KELLYANNE,
COCKROACHES WE KNOW VERMIN THAT
WORD WAS USED BY HITLER'S TWO
DESCRIBED.
>> kellyanne: LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING --
>> Laura: I TELL YOU I FOUND
THAT TO BE DOWN.
>> kellyanne: WITH THE WORD
DEHUMANIZATION AND THE WAY
PEOPLE HAVE TREATED THOSE OF US,
BUT SO WHAT?
I WILL GIVE YOU A LITTLE
NEWS FLASH, THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO CUT US
DOWN AND PUSHED US OUT SINCE WE
ARRIVED.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE THEY ARE FOR
THE RIGHT REASONS AND ARE
SURVIVING ALL OF THIS AND
THRIVING BEAUTIFULLY, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
I KNOW THAT IS TRUE ABOUT JEREMY
AS WELL.
THE MEDIA DOES NOT LIKE TO COVER
ANYTHING THEY ARE DOING.
WOMEN'S FUND OR WHAT IS DONE ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, PEACE,
TRADE MTA PRESIDENT HAD A BIG
MEETING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO COVER
ANYTHING BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
NOT SURE IT MATTERS SO MUCH.
I THINK THE MEDIA MATTERS TO
THEMSELVES AND EACH OTHER, BUT
THERE IS A LOT OF NOISE AND
NONSENSE OUT THERE.
I THINK PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY
ARE DOING MUCH BETTER, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT, I'M GLAD BECAUSE STOP
THE NONSENSE EVERYONE.
WE ARE PRO-WOMEN AND HERE FOR
INDEPENDENT THINKERS.
AND THE MONEY FOR THE PRESIDENT,
SHE TRIED TO APPROPRIATE
ETHNICITY AND SHE LIED ABOUT